I think there are good conversations to
be had
about a lot of stuff related to how we
handle the coronavirus you know we're
lockdowns effective was there enough
data to support the huge measures we
took
um you know why didn't we have the
option to show I was infected a month
ago why do I need to be vaccinated why
wasn't that option everything in the
United States I don't think it was there
are really good questions to be asked
there but all the people asking the
questions are also trying to tell you
that Ivermectin and monoclonal
antibodies are the way to go for
everything and the vaccine is evil and
it's going to turn you gay like the
frogs and it's like Jesus like you can
there's like no place to reasonably
criticize from because all of the people
that are criticizing aren't doing it
with an open mind or you know they're
not reading studies or do anything
they're saying like I do my own research
which means they listen to whatever the
last game Joe Rogan said and now they're
parroting that opinion easy no yeah as
you know the last guy on your work I'm
not sure working okay that Robert Malone
guy on Joe Rogan got me real fast one
guest people see him as like the father
of mRNA technology he published one
paper okay what do you mean people which
people think that Joe Rogan fans I get
like I run into these people I start
arguing when they start studying me what
about I'm a Joe Rogan fan and I
appreciate the vaccine that's good I'm
glad you do but there's definitely sorry
also but you said there's a type there's
a type what's the type what's the type
of Joe Rogan fan anti-establishment
I think that's not Joe Rogan that's a
that's a general public discourse
there's a default anti-establishment on
the on the right and the left that's the
default easy thing to go to I think Joe
Rogan fans are definitely a certain type
of anti-establishment though like I
could guess the Joe Rogan felt like if I
were to do general population versus Joe
Rogan fan who do you think is more
likely to be anti-vaccine
do you have data on this are you just
guessing yeah just guessing yeah I think
you are actually judging I am I think
you're judging because I think you're
also
the beautiful thing about podcasting
this could be similar streaming is
there's a large number of people that
just listen like what what does it mean
to be a Joe Rogan fan I don't think you
just listen I think people listen and
absorb the information I would say that
Joe Rogan fanbase is as divided in the
vaccine as the general public gotcha man
I'm gonna look for pulling data on that
I'm sure somebody's got to have done it
out there but no but you're you're
basically revealing the fact they have
no data you're using your own judgment
for sure uh based on how he's had
conversations about how his experience
with the coronavirus and then based on
the guests that have come on that have
talked and echoed a lot of like
anti-vaxx talking points and been
completely unchallenged and then based
on statements he's made about like
myocarditis and the vaccine and
everything as well yeah so the it's the
level of Challenge and not that he's
doing well yeah and then what his true
positions are and then the types of
guests he typically chooses to bring on
to talk about the vaccines yeah okay but
that represents somehow a deep
anti-establishment feeling versus just
the vaccine I mean I've seen the vaccine
and other things being
a thing that broke people they seem to
the front of virus that whole one or two
years broke a lot of people there's a
lot of emotion and emotion quickly uh
solidified into an opinion that almost
had nothing to do with like re like
thinking through and updating your
knowledge and so on you just made up a
made up your mind yeah but I think a lot
of it comes from that antisocial place
like what the vaccine represents the
ultimate of establishment it was a huge
private company backed by a huge uh
public government and there's fauci and
there's Biden and there's Pfizer and
there's all these countries locking us
up in our homes telling us to do a thing
like the vaccine was like the ultimate
like submission tool to like show you
that the government owns you not only
you have to get injected once it's a
series and then you got to get boosters
and it's like they're trying to keep you
under their thumb and it's that's the
control
um I Feel Like That vaccine became like
the ultimate rallying cry between like
do you support are you a sellout that is
going to believe whatever the government
tells the Sheep to take or are you going
to be like the guy that stands against
the crowd and gets fired from his job
and pulls his kids from school because
they're not going to let the evil fouchy
medicine you know jab them in the arm
and the funny thing is the crowd that
stands against
the institution is not larger than the
crowd of sheep there's like one sheep
standing there charm yeah or it feels
that way sometimes sheep well okay uh
what's the defensive institutions how do
you regain the trust of Institutions
like
for first of all do you think that
there's ways in which uh who CDC failed
and do you think there's criticism
towards Pfizer and the big Pharma
companies that's deserve it the Hamptons
the Pharma companies I'm not sure um for
CDC and who so here's a criticism that I
have of all of Academia and I feel it
stronger stronger every day I don't
think it's enough to be a researcher or
to be correct about issues Academia
needs to increase its ability to
communicate
um it is just an unbelievable
unmitigated failure that academics are
unwilling to wade into the complicated
topics uh that exist today because other
people are you know first you call me
spineless and then you call me a bad
communicator but no look you're here
you're doing it so you get props for me
okay good job but there are like so many
but I'm sure you've I'm sure that you
must have
um heard another fellow academic a
fellow colleague expressed some amount
of frustration about like and there's
specific discipline they know something
to be true and they know that like a lot
of the messaging is like wrong or bad in
the public about it but they're never
going to step out and say anything
because either one they're very measured
and careful with their take which they
feel is incompatible with what people
want to hear or two they're really
worried that they might be incorrect so
they're going to be cautious while
everybody else is going out in like
hardcore and they also don't have the
support of Institutions for them to go
out on a limb yeah so like to take risks
for example I've heard that with uh lab
League Theory I've had a lot of
biologists biologist friends that are
like yeah it's obviously leaked from a
lab like early on oh maybe okay we can
fight over this one but all right guys
we can fight over this like they okay I
should sort of backstep and say like
that's like you talk about shooting the
shed you haven't really investigated but
it's your gut like this doesn't make any
sense there would never say that
publicly of course mostly because you're
saying like what they would all say is
like we want to see data yeah which
would be good which is fine so they're
going with like like this is too many
coincidence in the same place that's the
the logic but they don't want to say
anything because there's no data you
need to have evidence you need to have
actual evidence to say one way or the
other there's that but there's also just
like you said I mean if effective
effective communication you're a fan of
Sean Carroll yes he's like one of the
only people in this whole planet that I
like besides you I love shortcuts
anytime Sean Carroll is brought up as
evidenced there's a smile that comes
over your face I love of like Joy yeah
of like a little kid thinking about
Santa Claus okay I love Sean Carol too I
love Sean Carroll because there I hate
this divide between like you're either
stem or you're like philosophy arts and
all that other stuff and the Two Worlds
come across and I love that it was so
good at physics but like explores and
pays attention to all of the like
sociological stuff too it's so rare to
find that quality in a person he's legit
one of the really really special minds
but you don't have to be a Sean Carl you
can be just a little better at educating
another person in the uh in the medical
in the health space is somebody named
Andrew huberman a friend of mine from uh
Stanford he's an incredible educator
there's the kind of process in science
that you should call like review or
survey papers where you basically
summarize all that's going on integrate
it and like draw wisdom from it and also
project like where's the discipline head
and and Andrew does that basically on
all these sub-components of the
different stuff going on in in
neuroscience and biology and
neurobiology all that he's able to he
does a podcast called huberman lab where
he just summarizes on and is able to
explain like what does that actually
mean for your for your life in terms of
Protocols of how to make your life
better I feel like people should be able
to do that more and more but with viral
virology and oh boy that's a tricky one
that's a really tricky one I wish that
people could have honest conversations
like I attack a lot of people that do
the lab League Theory stuff but truly we
should be able to have that conversation
publicly it just it always feels like
the people that are having the
conversation don't ever really want to
have the conversation they're not being
honest like like I'm a guy that like
does his own research and it's so boring
reading studies and a lot of it I can
only do abstracts and like I like it's
so much work but I'll never ever say
that about myself I'm a guy that does
his own research because every time I
hear somebody say that they don't do any
research when they say they do their own
research with immunities they've seen
one podcast and their opinion on this
podcast is that definitely not mine
because it was mine I wouldn't be
criticizing anything they say
um but yeah so like lab leak is another
one where it's like well how do you know
it's lap League how do I know it's lab
leak uh because fauci lied and Hunter
Biden uh laptop and it's like okay come
on you haven't engaged with it at all
there's really interesting interesting
research that shows us a really strong
study that shows that there's like a
high degree of certainty that it came
from the wet markets very very high
degree of certainty and there was an
article that came out recently where
it's like Senate concludes that virus
actually came from the Wuhan virology
lab or whatever
um and that whole article if you
actually read it it never says that in
the article I don't know why they
tweeted it with that headline
um but yeah it's to back up I'm sorry I
think we should have good you should be
sorry yeah I'm not sorry actually I get
to ramble here okay I'm here for a long
time I rescind my apology okay I
actually rescind my apology
um we should be able to have challenging
conversations about things but you gotta
man be well read on both sides not not
this like I do my own research so I
don't believe anything that fauci says
like come on dude do you think you can
do better than that not you personally
but gotcha
how does that feel it feels okay so
people who don't know that's the
catchphrase gotcha through all tragedy
and Triumph through all the roller
coaster of Life your response to is
gotcha